- Do people still freak out?
Like my thing, it's like
everybody comes come up
and yells, "Ah, Kelly Clarkson!"
Do people, and this is
your Hamilton, so it's like
do people always come up to you
and are just like talking to
you non-stop about Hamilton?
Because it was such a movement.
I feel like when I was a
kid, and Rent came out,
how popular that was and how it blew up,
that's what Hamilton
is for this generation.
It's just like enormous.
- It was that, and it, no,
it was weird, you know.
Davide used to say this
thing, this, I love,
that Davide used to say,
right outside the stage door,
"You were a beetle for a
block", you know what I mean?
(laughing)
Once you crossed 8th Avenue
it kind of died down,
but it took it took time to get used
to getting recognized at the
airport and stuff like that.
I'd be looking behind me like,
"Who are they looking at?".
But it was, you know, a huge phenomenon.
It changed our lives,
you know what I mean?
- [Kelly] Yeah the
trajectory of your, yeah.
But it also gave just
really talented people
a chance and opportunity
to really showcase all
that you are capable of.
Like how he wrote those songs.
I mean, my husband is a full on cowboy,
like raises cattle, road
bulls, like that kind of guy.
Tears.
We went to New York and he was like,
he was looking around going (mumbles)
(laughing)
He was like crying, like it was so good,
just such a great moment
in time, but I'm so glad
that you have the music
now that you're doing now.
I love that you're transitioning.